[Music]
in gross eats news submitted by JK party
field trip hmm was that was that you
take J because we're gonna eat that
stuff please do but there's gotta be a
field trip to eat pass stuff somewhere
yep
it makes sense the disgusting food
museum is showcasing 80 of the world's
grossest food oh we probably ate like
what's considered disgusting food oh
there's a lot of discussing Aidid for
one thing I saw I forgot I chose Native
American or Mexican but it's like rotten
corn more oh that's good dude okay or
whatever it's a it's on a core it's
purplish right purple it look crazy I
don't know it's just wow that's good
it's good and I'm [ __ ] good dude so
it's not it's not mold it's a fungus
that grows so it's like a mushroom oh is
it so it's really it's like called
huitlacoche some like that but it's like
super [ __ ] good like I've had it in
like blue corn tortillas and tacos yeah
it's like a tank ass mushroom it's good
oh okay well I just looked it looked
ugly to me yeah so that the the actual
mold or the the mushroom that grows from
it the fungi is worth more than the corn
I'm a fun guy yeah oh all that try that
super good do you just look would you
like mushroom cuz I'm a fungi alright
pickup lines just once the left but
they're just trying to be like a hate
yeah it's so dumb it's funny open mid
time in Sweden
mmm fun place yes their cheese smells
like [ __ ] is that where that nasty fish
that we tried oh yeah that was rotten
though Michael trying to [ __ ] us on that
pickled herring yeah it was a pickle it
was a pickled herring I like to go hurry
I think I was Harry if he's swedish
pickled herrings big there it was
exploded that [ __ ] had like e.coli and
[ __ ] botulism and [ __ ] all up in that
[ __ ] had all the bone
and everything but the meat fell off at
the Senate race it's like notorious for
its smell oh if it's if it just falls
off then not because pickled herring a
sperm yeah it was fully liquid like a
liquefied it was the Russians have one
that's pink so it's so polish and
Swedish people just because I know
because my cousin is polish
we have pickled herring everything's
giving so that's like a Swedish polish
thing that they always feed but it it's
like firm yeah that's what we try to eat
but it was rotten yeah you don't if it's
mushy it should not be like that it was
exploded and Mike was like it's fine
there is no fiber anymore there's no
there's no muscle fibers it's just it
was just a bone and like it looked like
fish shake throw um no that's not how
supposed to be and it was bubbling uh so
it ferment it in a bad way because it
can't explode it when we popped it open
oh yeah it shouldn't be like that that's
best it was like liquid in and we're
like I don't know if this is right it
looks wrong but in your mouth Michael
was some y'all did it for me we poked
the can the [ __ ] can whistled at us
for 30 seconds yeah that's like we're
like Oh Bart took like look that looked
it up and he's like I think we're
supposed to have whole fish yeah I
looked at the same exact brand on Google
Images and what was inside the can look
completely different than what we it was
an actual fish you do get to try it no
we ate the rotten one and almost
endangered our lives supposed to look
like this but it was not it was throw-up
yes yeah was that can supposed to look
like that yeah we just fine I eat
pickled fish all the time in the
description that says lightly salted the
one we had was like rotten because
there's there's a couple different ones
right so there's there's pickled herring
which people normally eat and there's
also a version of this like I smelled it
before and it does smell like death like
it's I forgot what is but it's hyper
fermented fish and I forgot what your it
might have been Sweden is that in the
museum place it's like you open it and
it smells like death and some people
like it but still people in like Sweden
like half of them hated or some like
that I'm not sure if it was Sweden but
it was a European there's something like
in there
Greenland or Iceland where they eat that
fermented shark or whatever have you
heard of supposed to be just as like
kind of disgusting in that same era like
only the locals can really eat it and
everyone else tries it the noise we I
know about this one is because I Andrew
Zimmern ate it he couldn't do it so it's
supposed to be hyper fermented it smells
like [ __ ] and then people like can macro
and sardines that they soak inside like
miso sauce or something
I like sardines it's so good Museum
they're gonna have three penis wine from
China what the [ __ ] penis a hundred
percent we already know what foods gonna
be in there Richard's gonna be like
three of the strongest animals dicks
that's inside that wine like we got a
tiger a gorilla and a [ __ ] zebra or
some [ __ ] deer seal and Cantonese black
dogs gonna be on there for sure
yes a bull penis from China oh don't
even oh I ate that [ __ ] do they eat
every part of that I knew though with
just cow stomachs
I'm sorry Rico looks good I used to hate
the [ __ ] flavor and menudo now I'm like
give me that what what happens is like
when some people make it they don't
really clean the fall very well and so
that organ taste goes into the smells
like a [ __ ] yeah so you know they're
like in Asia to Bill you know if you
have like organ meat in a soup they'll
usually cook it off in a different
that's before they put it in there that
could still drink the broth and eat the
hominy but the meat I won't eat you
right the tripe whatever meat is in
there that's crazy yeah I don't need
that honeycomb tripe I hate that [ __ ]
like it's delicious okay next one is
fruit bats
wrong they just straight-up eat bad I
don't know it's crazy
where's the me yo fruit bats are huge
too by the way there's some big ass
[ __ ]
keeping everything that thing looks
crazy I like how they try to make it all
presentable on a bed of lettuce and [ __ ]
jell-o salad salad family you are cool
that's what you a yeah that's like a
1940's dish we're like all lives and
what the [ __ ] else is that you never
seen that before I know they're trying
to say probably white people made that
[ __ ] but um like fruitcake no it's it's
I've seen it before like the the like
those old-school 1940 1957 true but not
olives yeah I see yeah you fruit never
seen all that with fruit in it but cuz
jello sells it like that the company
right but I've never seen jello with
[ __ ] all of them
what about steak inside Oh all right
next one neat oh yeah they were king no
I always forget the only other needle I
know good not though is van I've tried
not though it was [ __ ] nasty yeah got
changed no you didn't try it right you
didn't you you didn't eat it hooked up
like you still nasty fact that I have
this [ __ ] slobber okay but that's
like you know what do you like well a
prob in Chi Chi and it's Passarella
and the spring me a tepee I'll eat the
cheese in the same I just learned to
like cheese like maybe ten years ago
like growing up I hated cheese good not
though if you get it cuz in the packet
comes with that sweet soybean yes and
the [ __ ] sesame seeds in the food a
cockade thing yeah bro if you do that
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] Japanese soft white
bread toast that [ __ ] put knocked over
it and a [ __ ] egg it's hella good
you know what I know you got to I don't
like it cuz it looks like peanuts and I
want to eat peanuts well eat peanuts
another day that looks good you know
what I do I mix that with okra and raw
egg and I put like a little fermented
plum in the bushy and then you put and
it's like extra snotty oh yes sir it's
like extra loogie I love that sticky
fluid to me right strips smells like an
open butthole though it smells like a
dying like dying flush like it smells
like rotten so now Yes Mother beans to
me yeah it only smells like beans you
grew up with this and you grow up with
speedy tofu yeah you you cut your your
incentive there just think you smell his
own farts so that tells you a lot well
what next one that looks like Dookie in
a pot Oh words from Limbach way oh they
love that [ __ ] worm yeah I bet you all
of this [ __ ] is good
nope yeah so then I think do that I
cannot do that
Mongolia yeah look at this I bet you
that juice is bringing it all those
holes are too oh yeah that's from Greece
from Sardinia
yes Sardinia dude like I saw this [ __ ]
it's an island in 20 minutes doc you on
this [ __ ] so they can't even really sell
it anymore because of the state that
it's in so the only way you can get
there somebody makes it so there's like
a couple of like how else would you get
it
no I'm talking about somebody makes it
at home homemade so you can't buy it is
what I'm saying commercial you can't
exactly so because you know it's a
little iffy you have maggots it's part
of gives some sort of law yeah but then
you eat it with the maggots and
everything yes but what they like about
that is the maggot
eats the cheese shits it out and it
turns it into something else so they're
eating maggots [ __ ] plus the maggot it's
supposed to be hyper ammoniated too so
it just smells like ammonia
like like Windex down - it's crazy
I'd rather smell Windex and there's like
cat [ __ ] coffee elephant [ __ ] coffee but
you're not consuming the coffee bean
either so that's maybe a little bit
different
well you're just crushing it up and
drinking there's there's nothing wrong
with a double-double
well don't they risk the beat don't they
rinse the bean yeah it's all clean as
roasted and stuff so you know this is
actual maggot [ __ ] and oh yeah live
maggots level I saw them eating it and
then they would just like eat it like
it's like a [ __ ] guacamole and [ __ ]
Michael like the way they described it -
it's like that ammonia like fume just
goes through your nasal cavities and
everything it's that prevalent and a lot
of people don't like it so it's like
very particularly are they putting the
whole country just smell a urinal you
know what I think why humans develop
this kind of [ __ ] is is like when your
body is lacking a certain type of
mineral nutrient or whatever or or
probiotic it starts to like what [ __ ]
like that like dirt people start crazy
yeah thanks I need iron there's like a
it's called like a Mississippi Mud Pie
up something like that but when they
were iron deficient they would actually
get the red dirt yeah and put it into
their pie and eat that [ __ ] I must be
like dessert deficient yeah mouth wine
from China baby my baby money that's
[ __ ] tragic that's diseased that's
tragic boil it
I don't know I don't know how they
prepare my dad makes his own moonshine I
there's no rats in it there's no rats in
there yeah ain't nobody drinking that
shitty your dad's moonshine looks like
vegetable moonshine yeah it's all kinds
of crazy herbs I says makes them strong
at night Jerry and stinky tofu Oh stinky
tofu dude what the [ __ ] man a whole
bunch of other crazy [ __ ] so the museum
opens October 29 until January I wonder
if you could smell all this [ __ ] I miss
good stinky tofu there's good stinky
tofu
[Music]